kendall Jenner and Bella Hadid live it
up in London and Greece these two sure
do know how to Jet's a pendulum Bela
attended the Pride Parade in London on
Saturday rockin rainbow hats and crop
tops that showed off their killer abs
it's so awesome
Bella captioned this shot quote hashtag
Love Wins hashtag London the supermodels
also attended the 2017 Wireless Festival
in London with Kendall's little sister
Kylie who watched her new man Travis
Scott perform at the Music Fest then it
was off to the Greek isle of Mykonos
where they hit up a friend's beach
birthday party at the Sunday bash
Kendall sported a black dress sans bra
while Bella opted for a white bikini and
tight white cover-up everything's like
so good right now the gal pals splashed
around in the water and when the Sun set
Bella shared this shot writing tonight
but it wasn't all play both ladies were
in Europe to strut their stuff on the
catwalk during Paris Fashion Week it's
really nice to have friends that's close
in like this industry now that's what we
call a good work-life balance
[Music]